>>> IN OUR SERIES "A MORE
PERFECT UNION," WE AIM TO SHOW
THAT WHAT UNITES US AS AMERICANS
IS FAR, FAR GREATER THAN WHAT
DIVIDES US.
COMMERCIAL PHOTOGRAPHY IS AN
ESTIMATED $2 BILLION WITH A B
INDUSTRY.
MORE THAN 70% OF THE
PHOTOGRAPHERS ARE WHITE.
IN LOS ANGELES, ONE NONPROFIT IS
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES BY
OFFERING PHOTOGRAPHY CLASSES TO
TEENAGE GIRLS IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
LILIA LUCIANA, ONE OF THE GREAT
NAMES, SHOWS HOW THEY'RE
CHANGING LIVES AND THE INDUSTRY.
>> Reporter: IN THE SHADOW OF
THE DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES
SKYLINE, EAST L.A. IS HOME TO A
VIBRANT STREET ART SCENE THAT
CAPTURES THE HEART AND SOUL OF
THE LATINX COMMUNITY.
TODAY'S YOUNGER GENERATION OF
CREATORS AREN'T JUST USING
PAINTBRUSHES.
THEY'RE USING CAMERAS.
>> KEEP YOUR HEAD THERE AND LOOK
AT ME.
>> Reporter: MARIA ROAM REA
JOINED THE LOS FOTOS PROJECT
FOUR YEARS AGO.
WERE YOU INTERESTED IN
PHOTOGRAPHY BEFORE?
>> I DIDN'T GROW UP WITH LIKE
ANYONE WHO WAS A PHOTOGRAPHER OR
AN ARTIST.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT I HAD ACCESS
TO THIS.
♪
>> Reporter: THE NONPROFIT
STARTED IN 2010 TO HELP YOUNG
LATINAS BUILD SELF-CONFIDENCE
THROUGH PHOTOGRAPHY.
STUDENTS ARE GIVEN A LAPTOP,
CAMERA, AND FREE CLASSES TAUGHT
BY PROFESSIONALS.
THEY LEARN BASIC PHOTOGRAPHY,
PHOTO JOURNALISM, AND
ENTREPRENEURIAL SKILLS.
LUCIA TORRES IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
>> THEY'RE BEING OFFERED A FORUM
AND SPACE TO STEP INTO THEIR
POWER.
>> Reporter: THE TEENS' PHOTOS
HAVE BEEN FEATURED IN ART
MUSEUMS, NATIONAL NEWSPAPERS,
AND PRESENTED TO UNITED NATIONS
AMBASSADORS.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO ON DISPLAY
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AT LOCAL
EXHIBITIONS AND PUBLIC PARKS.
>> SEEING HOW PEOPLE ARE JUST IN
AWE OF THIS IMAGERY AND
PHOTOGRAPHY, AND IT'S THEM,
THEY'RE THE SUBJECTS, THEY'RE
THE PEOP WHO ARE IN THIS
PHOTOGRAPH.
IT'S EVERYDAY PEOPLE AND THEIR
EVERYDAY WORLD AND EVERYDAY
LIVES.
>> Reporter: 18-YEAR-OLD ROMINA
ESTRADA SAYS PHOTOGRAPHY GAVE
HER THE CONFIDENCE TO MEET NEW
PEOPLE AND BUILD RELATIONSHIPS.
>> BEFORE I JOINED LOS FOTOS I
WAS VERY SHY AND INTROVERTED.
I THINK IT'S BROUGHT ME OUT OF
MY SHELL.
>> Reporter: WHAT DO YOU FEEL
YOU'RE PROVIDING TO YOUR
COMMUNITY?
>> I THINK A FEELING OF
CLOSENESS AND A FEELING OF LIKE
REPRESENTATION.
I WENT UP TO PEOPLE AND THEY
WERE LIKE, WHOA, I'VE NEVER HAD
LIKE MY PHOTO TAKEN.
THANK YOU FOR THIS.
>> Reporter: ROMERO SAYS THE
GROUP BECAME A REFUGE AFTER SHE
IMMIGRATED FROM MEXICO WHEN SHE
WAS 12.
>> I WAS SO SAD TO LEAVE.
I REMEMBER I COULDN'T SLEEP.
SORRY.
I HADN'T TALKED ABOUT THIS IN A
LONG TIME.
>> Reporter: IT SOUNDS
OVERWHELMING, ESPECIALLY AT AN
AGE THAT IS ALREADY
OVERWHELMING.
>> YEAH.
I WAS SO AFRAID TO SPEAK ENGLISH
IN FRONT OF LIKE MY CLASSMATES
THAT I WOULD ONLY DO IT WHEN I
WAS ALONE IN CLASS WITH MY
TEACHERS.
>> Reporter: DO YOU FEEL LIKE
PHOTOGRAPHY IN A WAY GAVE YOU A
VOICE?
>> WITH PHOTOGRAPHY, I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SHOW MY EMOTIONS.
>> Reporter: SHE ALSO FOUND A
HOME AWAY FROM HOME.
>> IT'S NOT JUST A PHOTOGRAPHY
PROGRAM, IT'S A COMMUNITY FOR
GIRLS WHO ARE STRUGGLING, WHO
HAVE THE SAME STRUGGLES, WHO
HAVE THE SAME EXPERIENCES.
AND WE ARE ABLE TO CONNECT.
>> Reporter: WITH GUIDANCE FROM
FULL-TIME PHOTOGRAPHERS, ROMERO
AND ESTRADA HAVE BEEN HIRED FOR
PROFESSIONAL GIGS, PAYING JOBS
THAT THEY HOPE COULD LEAD TO
LONG-TERM CAREERS.
>> IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL AND
EMPOWERING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CAMERA AND BE ABLE TO LIKE SAY
I'M A PROFESSIONAL PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> Reporter: FOR "CBS THIS
MORNING," LILIA LUCIANO, LOS
ANGELES.
>> VERY COOL.
>> MARIA ROMERO,
ADMINISTRATADMINISTRATION
I
CHEERING -- CHEERING YOU ON.
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT GIVES THEM
CONFIDENCE.
>> IT'S INTERESTING THAT GOING
BEHIND THE CAMERA CAN BRING
SOMEBODY OUT MORE.
>> YEAH.
>> NAYSAY IT'S NOT JUST -- THEY
SAY IT'S NOT JUST A PHOTO CLUB,
IT'S A COMMUNITY.
IT'S POWERFUL.
IT TELLS YOU TO STOP, IT FREEZES
THE MOMENT.
LOOK AND FEEL SOMETHING.
I LOVE IT.
WELL DONE, LILI